sending out a decoy
you got blam boozled it's like
bamboozled
with a blimp pursue your fortune with
the season five
battle pass featuring an adventurous new
set of legendary items
you came looking for trouble but trevor
find your best
immediately unlock the legendary
retrofitted hemlock at purchase
along with three new legend skins
conquer the remaining 100 levels
to earn the rest of the rewards
including legendary items like fool's
gold mirage
sky marshall bangalore and the reactive
precision caliber wingman
you gotta take the good with the bad i'm
good you're bad
as always season five continues to let
legends personalize their experience
with new music packs loading screens and
banners
themed banter for the quip wheel you
might still live on
i've seen ghosts around here a new
series of luxurious gun charms
and of course a new batch of
death-defying skydive emotes
losing isn't fun that's why i don't do
it
unlock your battle pass right now or
upgrade to the bundle to immediately
unlock those first 25 levels
and venture into battle with fool's gold
learn the steps before you try to tango
with me
fortune favors the bold and your next
adventure awaits
only with the season 5 battle pass
you